I don't want to spread no more of that violence in the air.
I just want to hang out and entertain now.
I want to dance and sing.
I want to be like Billy Madison.
Remember that show? Anybody see that?
Billy Madison is a boxer, and he turns into a ballet singer,...
...ballet dancer.
I just don't have the desire to be that guy anymore.
I was explaining before, me being that guy, I couldn't have lived well...
...I could never have a relationship with my wife and my children.
That guy takes up so much of my life,...
...that I, Mike, whoever the hell that guy is, he just takes up too much and not in a good perspective either.
I do have some plans to play characters and stuff.
I play myself pretty good.
I'm a pretty interesting character.
You know, I am a character.
Mike Tyson is a character,...
...and playing myself is playing a character.
I get paid like I'm playing somebody else too.
So, if the show is gonna play Mike Tyson,...
...other guys are being paid much money being me...
...so being me is pretty profitable.